football avec le match au sommet de la
19e journée de régionale 1 disputée
devant leur public et des occasions de
but comme bouille elle qui n'a pas
inquiété vos arsène le gage de l'ifa
6,15 c'est au tour de marajo cette fois
ci de mettre en difficulté gaubert le
tournant de cette première période la
versys évident et le père à tiago
biographe aussi ce qu'est marajo à la
lutte avec côte d'ivoire est l'antidote
il est transformé par patrick personne
qui croit au titre que deux champions de
mentalité
on a eu de quoi lui et on va en premier
le championnat est encore long on a
notre destin entre nos mains donc ils
sont obligés d'être ne faut pas de notre
part mais on va pas leur donner cette
chance on va se battre jusqu'au bout
le golden gate 2 c'est joseph arracher
l'égalisation fait partie par kevin
parent se lever sur coup franc le buteur
a permis à son club de rester dans la
course au titre de champion régional
c'est un match difficile sans voiture
low cost qui nous a poussés dans nos
derniers retranchements
ils ont une première mi-temps plutôt
aboutie mais nous aussi on a une
deuxième mi-temps aboutit donc si je
trouve que c'était plutôt mérité de
revenir au score ne serait pas forcément
évident mais on a assuré l'essentiel
le championnat n'est pas fini et
fédérant continue dans cette compétition